so for the majority of my life I
struggled to go to the gym consistently
even though the gym has always been a
part of my life to some degree I grew up
playing hockey and all my brothers
played hockey and went to the gym so
going to the gym was always the right
thing to do but I can never stay
consistent even into university
sometimes I would go two weeks straight
at the gym and then take a month off I
try to get into a groove and hype myself
up and I really wanted to look like Thor
and then I lost my hair the whole point
of this story is to let you know that if
you relate to this I've been in that
exact same place but I've managed in
recent years to develop a tremendous
consistency at the gym and it takes me a
lot less effort to get there than it
previously ever has and I can credit
this a lot to a particular mindset I've
adopted when it comes to doing things
that I find difficult or boring and sort
of tricking my brain into liking these
things I've also been able to apply this
strategy to other areas of my life most
specifically to reading books and
editing videos essentially what I did is
I stopped generating motivation by
thinking about an end goal and instead I
learned to enjoy the process so first of
all what's wrong with visualizing an end
goal why not use this image of this
Beachbody or Greek God physique as
motivation to workout well the main
problem you'll face is the fact that
there is a huge disparity between what
it feels like to fantasize about this
Greek god physique and what it feels
like to actually be at the gym pushing
heavy weights they're a completely
different sensation fantasizing about
having an awesome body feels awesome it
puts you in this sort of lala land where
you're just walking around as this
imaginary version of yourself actually
going to the gym it's strenuous it's
sweaty and it's often really boring
especially if you're doing cardio on a
treadmill it's like the most boring
thing I've ever encountered in my life
that's the first problem the second
problem that you face when you try to
generate your motivation from this ideal
image of yourself is that it will always
be a moving target no matter how much
you fantasize about this perfect version
of yourself you will never feel like you
have arrived and even if you were to
hypothetically arrive at this goal
there's something called
entropy
stagnation breeds destruction if you
just sit on your winnings everything
will fall apart you need to keep moving
you have to love the daily discipline of
going to battle every single day and
finding pleasure and fulfillment in the
thing in the present moment for its own
sake if you're able to do this then
that's the happy place the thing itself
will generate its own motivation as you
do it and you can become fully immersed
in the activity you're doing so am i
saying it's bad to have goals in general
not at all goals are really good for
creating direction having an ideal is
sort of like having a compass it's
leading you in the right direction you
should take a glance at it for reference
but in the day to day struggle of
actually doing the thing it's not what
you should be focusing on so now that we
know why it's kind of unhelpful to
always think about this end goal now
you're probably thinking how do I learn
to enjoy and embrace difficult things
and have it be an integrated part of my
life so there are two things that really
help me do that
number one is more of a mindset shift in
it's more inner work and number two is
more of a practical strategic thing that
you do to yourself okay so number one is
to operate from an abundance mindset
rather than a scarcity mindset when you
think to yourself I need to go get
jacked do you think that's an abundance
mindset or a scarcity mindset that is a
scarcity mindset because you need to go
get something and that applies that you
don't already have it when you say I
need to go to the gym because I need to
go get jacked you're subconsciously
saying to yourself that's because I'm
not jacked yet which also implies to
yourself that you're not jacked and as
I've mentioned in previous videos human
beings have any mate sense of wanting to
stay intellectually consistent whatever
you think your identity is you will
operate accordingly so if you are
constantly telling yourself that you are
not jacked what do not jack people do
they don't go to the gym when you look
at it that way going to the gym will
always be something that's outside of
yourself it's something that's unnatural
for you why would you go to the gym if
you're not jacked so am i saying you
should do some like woowoo thing and
pretend that you're jacked all of a
sudden like force yourself to
know that you are in fact a giant beast
that's not what I'm saying because
that's not true
instead try reminding yourself that the
reason why you want to go to the gym is
because you're an active person and
going to the gym is something that is
important to you your health is
important to you so since you're an
active person going to the gym is just
something you do that gets rid of a ton
of mental resistance in the way of
actually going to the gym you can use
this exact same method for reading books
if you're constantly telling yourself
like oh I have to go read books to get
smarter oh I have to go read a book now
like obviously you're not gonna have a
good time while you're doing it
but if you identify as somebody who
enjoys reading books it's something that
you like doing it's just a part of who
you are then you're way more likely to
actually follow through with doing it
and if you think this is just some
woowoo crap this is how some of the
greatest musicians athletes and
performers operate take John Mayer for
example I was just watching one of his
Instagram live videos where he was
jamming out to Blues back tracks and he
was having the time of his life and he
said on the actual live stream nothing's
more fun in this lifetime going out to
dinner and coming home and picking up
guitar and just practicing just playing
I don't even call practice because even
the word practice implies that you're
only doing it to achieve some sort of
outcome but if you're playing you're
just enjoying it for what it is so when
I'm playing free I'm like and I'm kind
of doing what I do at home which is
repeat the same stuff over and over
again because it feels really good this
next tip is a little bit more practical
and a little less theoretical and that
is to utilize habit bunching and that is
when you pair an already existing habit
that you are used to doing with one that
you're trying to work on so for instance
I'm a sucker for a great cup of coffee I
have one in the morning and one in the
early afternoon I really enjoy the taste
of coffee and I look forward to it every
single time do I have an addiction yes
but I can leverage this filthy habit of
mine into working on another habit a
great one to pair with a coffee
addiction is reading and that's exactly
how I started reading more books every
single morning next to my coffee maker I
placed the book that I wanted to read
next to it so that when I made my coffee
I knew to pick up the book and I could
only drink the coffee if I was reading
the book the entire time I was drinking
it done and the
thing about this is eventually you just
start getting used to reading whether
you have coffee or not the action of
opening up a book and reading becomes a
lot more natural it'll become something
very pleasant to you that's so much
better than reading for the end goal of
becoming smarter like what is getting
smarter even feel like it doesn't feel
like anything it's not like in the
matrix where they download kung-fu onto
neo all of a sudden you just feel it
habit bunching also works really well
when you're trying to develop a gym
habit if you have an album that you are
currently in the habit of listening to
and you crave the sound of posts
Malone's beautiful sweet silky melodies
then you should leverage that allow
yourself to listen to posts Malone but
only when you're at the gym this is one
of the main ways I started to become
consistent at the gym I had this migos
album that would like pump me up so much
even though I'm looking back on it now
it's like not even good music at all and
just like drinking coffee and reading
once you start using habit bunching to
develop a positive association with the
habit you're trying to work on then your
entire mindset towards that thing shifts
pretty soon you will just like going to
the gym because of the way it makes you
feel and realize that it's less about
the music that's actually making you
feel so good and it's more about the
endorphins of pushing heavy weight and
getting stronger
so to summarize stop generating your
motivation on a day to day basis by
fantasizing about some sort of end goal
that you're never going to arrive at
instead use the appropriate mindset
shifts and the habit bunching tool and
whatever other tools at your disposal
you have to help you love the process
and help you love doing these things for
their own sake huge shout out to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video for
those of you who don't know Skillshare
is an online learning platform with
thousands of classes covering dozens of
topics everything from photography to
productivity to learning how the stock
market works which is actually the exact
topic that I've sunk my teeth into
recently on Skillshare as I build my
business and start making more money I
know that it's only a matter of time
before I start investing unfortunately I
know pretty much nothing about the stock
market and it's always been something
that I really wanted to learn
more about which obviously if I'm going
to invest in the stock market I would
want to know what I'm doing first
luckily there's this awesome class that
I discovered on Skillshare by a guy
named business casual and he has two
classes on just an introduction to how
the stock market works and how all the
different elements come into play and I
feel my mind expanding already pretty
soon I'm gonna be like Eddie Mora from
lemon lessons just start making millions
of dollars overnight Skillshare is
offering better ideas viewers two months
completely free off a Premium Membership
if you use the link in the description
which means right now absolutely free
you can check out business casuals class
on the stock market and learn as much as
I'm learning right now after your free
trial expires Skillshare is actually
still very affordable if you sign up for
the annual membership your monthly hit
is less than $10 a month so once again
hit the link in the description to get
two months of skill shaped premium
absolutely free if you like this video
make sure to hit like because when you
hit like the algorithm blesses me with
shoving this video in front of other
people's faces this will be especially
helpful if somebody's struggling to go
to the gym and my tips in this video
helped them randomly because my face
popped up on their home page if you're
lurking here consider subscribing and
hitting the bell icon so you don't miss
when I make new videos also our
notification squad is growing last time
I checked it was over twenty thousand
which means over twenty thousand people
get notified like actually get a pop-up
notification when I upload a new video
and if you're part of the notification
squad there's a way higher chance that I
can actually respond to your comments I
can heart your comments I can pin your
comments really exciting things
happening on the channel I'll actually
be uploading next week based on atomic
habits by James clear but that's all for
today thank you for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video